[Music]
uh you look great oh thank you very much
uh first of all congratulations the the
offense a big success
people love the show and we take a
little bit of pride here at late night
because uh you don't realize mindy you
started as an
intern on our show skipped internet
stripped intern on our program
how long ago was that i'm trying to
think i think it was six years ago six
years ago
and uh so now you've gone on obviously
to to bigger and better things
tell us just a little bit what was it
like interning here did you was it a
good experience
yeah interning was so much fun i think
it's like a prerequisite now on the
office that you have to have
interned here because between me and
john krasinski and it's
this is not a joke this is true uh other
interns on our show and also populating
the cast of the office
john krasinski started as an intern on
our show angela
kinsey started as an intern on our show
and that mindy you're also on the
program you start as an intern
other little-known interns that went on
to big things harrison ford was an
intern on our show
morgan freeman was an intern here for a
while and charlton heston started with
us back
in the 40s
actually my favorite story when i was
interning here was um
it was actually a moment with you where
i was carrying all these scripts and i
got into the elevator
and it was just you and i you stepped in
it was you and i the elevator and you to
be polite
said oh what's your major and i blurted
out
art history which was not my major
because i was so nervous
why did you lie to me i don't know i was
so nervous that
i was just i was petrified and um then
you were like oh it's very interesting
and you had
like a follow-up question was like oh
the venus of willendorf and i was
sitting there being like please
god let this elevator right hand why
have i lied like this so badly
this makes me sound like the most boring
elevator mate in the world
oh yes our history let me ask you
jato's triptychs the 15th century but i
just the
doors open and i like bolted out you ran
away that's usually what happens with me
and interns
like i've got to get away from this
horrible horrible man
uh so then you very uh
yet success right away shortly after
interning here you sold
a pilot is that right yes i had um i
wrote a pilot with my best friend and
writing partner brenda
and we wrote this show called mindy and
brenda which was the story of
our lives in brooklyn before we moved to
l.a and we were really excited about it
but then um
on the wb they said we thought we were
going to be playing the parts
and then they said ah no we're gonna um
audition the parts of mindy and brenda
and um we had to go in and audition
for our own parts wait a minute so we
looked after ourselves
and we didn't get the parts that's the
wait so you wrote it
you wrote it about yourselves for
yourselves characters are named indian
brendan sure and then you had to
audition and you didn't get it no we
were considered not convincing enough as
mindy and brenda
so that was my first experience and so
like when we uh
when the cast of the office won the
screen actors killed last week i was
like
oh i guess like i'm not so bad at
playing other parts just
not myself apparently you can't play
yourself no i can't
now uh do you like working i'm curious
of steve carell he's been on the show
many times
he seems like a great guy is he fun and
i got to work with him a little here and
there is he fun to work with
steve's reputation is that he's the
nicest guy in hollywood and he actually
is
and i um my favorite interaction with
him once is that um
my boyfriend at the time beard passing
resemblance to him
and so i um ran up to him from behind
and i grabbed him and was like hey baby
and i kissed the back of his neck
and steve was like hey baby
like that was like a private joke we had
or something instead of being like get
the hell off of me
he took it he reacted well he went with
it yeah he was totally sweet
and then um and i had to go around and
pretend like hey baby was something i
did to perfect strangers
yeah he's a nice guy
you